you film on location in Nepal and also I
think you know actors they get movies
and they think oh great I get to go to
that place but this is unbelievable I
think that the way that television I
mean I know it's a broadcast medium but
yeah you get to Nepal and they know who
you are I mean it it was um it was
unbelievable because I was quite I was
in that stage of the film so I'm quite
bearded up and all scraggly and
desperate and even despite that I was on
the first day photographed and that was
it and by the end there were thousands
of people surrounding us there was one
very scary moment these people started
crowding around the car we could we
couldn't move and it was literally like
being the opposite it was was not was
like being in a mobile cage it wasn't
going anywhere in a zoo it was really
weird I had conversations with it and
then it was like that's a nice shirt man
and I thought no we really actually
we're kind of like half an hour late and
the car started rocking a bit with new
people turning up that pushing the new
people like I think the first people to
write we were a bit embarrassed because
their faces were basically press the
case so we sort of only pushed the car
door open saying sorry sorry we really
have to go just made up and just ran
there were hundreds of people burnin it
Sherlock it's incredible it's just got
nuts and it is I mean what does you mind
cuz you are like a Nerds wet dream
because you've got you go Sherlock Star
Trek and now Marvel ah thank God some I
know is that
that's that's your pension right there
you can just do the motion get properly
lazy devil I actually did just go and
sign pictures of my face but there's a
there was a shot that I think you were
on location in New York and so this is
without oh yeah this is without the
special effect so this is Doctor Strange
is that the what do you have got energy
rubber bands take off or you take yeah
oh that's that's me about to fly okay
fly anywhere for some reason the way
these things do that image just captured
people's imaginations they've taken that
I just saw straight you put it in
different places
so here's Benedict and as its choir he's
also very sporty there you he's also
cultured music is his life very good at
the ice skating ladies and gentlemen
that was like it's real Donald Trump
move
by the way we're sorry we're so sorry
it's nearly over
graham norton air if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation